do you have time to play with your kids  are you too busy oh yeah we play yeah  yeah hang out with we go to I do all the  soccer games and stuff but but I had to  learn how to play white people y'all  having so much playtime man yeah  just it's just frivolous play you know I  like it like wizzy yeah black people  always waiting for something to happen  we always own old gold point like it's  always playing going on in my house so I  had to get used today because you know  black people don't play  that's just how we were raised no no  jigsaw puzzle I well that's different  I'm while I'm doing a jigsaw puzzle I'm  also looking around seeing what's going  away I will not stop talking until you  subscribe to my youtube channel that's  right and I could talk a lot seriously  not gonna stop yep still here not going  anywhere I see you don't walk away from  this